[Music]
it's been a year on Friday since you
were nominated I believe quite yeah well
yeah I mean it's there was a couple yeah
the official nomination right yeah how'd
you look back well it was a tremendous I
mean I just remembered as being a
tremendous day for myself and my wife
and my family and my mother is 97 and
everybody it's a great honor to be given
this this job it had been talked about
earlier but this is the official day so
was it a surprise
no because the president announced kind
of at meetings he kind of made
announcements that that I was his choice
but it wasn't official quite
controversial there isn't either
president is it's sometimes quite
difficult to represent his views here in
the United Kingdom I don't think so no I
think mr. ambassador surely it is no not
for me
no I'm a believer you know I know what
what you know the rationale behind his
election and why people voted for him so
when I have to explain you know what he
did what he says in his Twitter or what
his actions are it's I tend to look down
the road where he wants to take
everybody rather than the bumps along
the road and focus on the daily you know
interested the daily tweets or a lot and
I think where he's taking us I mean the
proof is in the pudding really the
American economy is booming like it
hasn't and you know decades we had
almost 5% growth initially reported last
quarter if you told me that 500 days ago
I would have said there's no possible
way but with tax cuts and all of the
regulation reform and all that that he's
done and probably most importantly by is
just his general leadership as a
business person he's got everybody fired
up and it okay so your economy's doing
well what about what we saw with the
latest g7 meeting and the tariffs that
were imposed and it looked like every
other Lee
I saw that amazing photograph of him
with his arms folded and they were all
challenging him he does seem to be out
of step from the rest of the world on
occasion do you not think that's a very
interesting photograph yeah because all
of the leaders are looking to him for
leadership and while he has his hands
folded they're all paying attention to
just him so I think they realized that
his direction also and he made this
statement after that you know explaining
a g7 meeting that a lot of what's been
going on has been unfair and they're not
free in terms of terms of trade and
relations and I think he's just trying
to write the course and he said that
they all understood that okay so how do
we interpret that when it comes to
brexit because they're obviously you
know that our country is very anxious
about brexit on all sorts of levels
worried about what might happen as far
as the economy is concerned we don't
need a president folding his arms and
and feeling that we are out of step with
him when we're turning to you for help
and support when we leave Europe well I
think the president is leading leading
the world in a new way and these are not
new views for the president you know
I've known the president since the early
80s
and he expressed these views about
really not blaming current leadership in
Europe or just even even Obama a
previous leadership but going back way
back that the trade relations and what
the American people but the American
leadership has done has really been in
quote stupid and so I think he's said
upon he mentioned this a lot in his
campaign and he's fulfilling that
campaign promise I think because he
really believes it so what the trade
relations look like between the u.s. and
the UK post brexit I think it's gonna
really be good I mean he's made that
statement if the if the brexit agreement
leaves an opening a big opening for the
u.s. to have that bilateral relationship
I think will occur very rapidly that's
what the president said that's what the
people in department of commerce and
trade have also said so I'll take them
out to a word on that okay just a quick
thought on policy and then and then I
want to talk to you a bit a little bit
more about the politicians here
separation
of immigrants and little ones being kept
in cages in Texas we've seen our TV
screens and little ones calling for
their mums and dads I mean that's very
emotive staff well this is a very
emotional issue and it's one that I've
been looking closely at in terms of all
the underlying some of the underlying
issues that are involved in it yeah this
is something that the Democrats and
Republicans have to not fold but they
have to solve this problem
and the president's sworn to protect the
borders sovereignty and you know protect
from criminal elements and drugs and all
that mm 13 and all those those threats
that we have but he also you know feel
strongly about about you know protecting
young children so so this is something
that Congress can uniquely do and the
Congress should step up and get it done
but your your father mr. ambassador how
do you feel when you see those images of
those two little ones
I think it's emotional I get them up you
know it's emotional to have that
separation there's a lot of issues
regarding this besides separated their
connect from from their families it just
they're two and three years old mm-hmm
this is something that Congress there
this is a great motivation the first
lady's have talked about it and I think
they've added their their views and I
think that will push Congress hopefully
to make some some good decisions that we
can protect the border and protect our
national sovereignty and protect the
kids as well let's move on Street and
let's talk about politicians here you
took you brought up the president's
tweets they are very well known of
course at what what's your relationship
like with Sadiq Khan armored with him
Sadiq Khan the Mayor of London my
relation is very good but I don't deal
with a daily basis but he and I have a
very nice cordial relationship he
doesn't have a great relationship with
the president does he hear you trying to
smooth that over oh no I don't I don't I
think the relationships fine I mean they
can agree they can agree to disagree on
certain things and maybe they get they
get hot on sir
issues but that I don't think that's
affecting the overall relationship mr.
Kahn said recently he's a reluctant
partner in the dialogue on Twitter and
he's not clear what mr. Trump's beef is
with him yeah but I think there's been a
there's been a quid pro quo as far as
that thing goes but in terms of in terms
of the governance of the city in terms
of the vibrancy of what's going on in
London and what's going on in the u.s.
in our cities yeah I mean there's a lot
of more commonality than there is
difference it did say that at North an
East London hospital was like a war zone
with blood on the floor yeah there's
been statements but you know it's all
you know I think once again it
emphasizes the his his job to keep the
country safe keep Americans safe look at
cyber look at local policing look at all
the issues revolved around maintaining a
sovereign city and a rule of law and how
do you feel about living in London you
don't feel that there are any no-go
zones where you can't go no not that
I've heard of travel anywhere Oh God
everywhere okay you're fantastic new
Embassy has just opened you don't think
you're gonna show us a route I love it
it's good as you can see the
neighborhood is expanding dramatically
it's probably the fastest growing area
in the UK right now the cranes virtually
in every direction so this prosperity is
happening a lot of jobs a lot of
concrete there'll be a lot of infill and
this space will be beautiful can we have
a look right sure
Wow look at your view that's amazing
yes not bad yeah you want to take a look
yes please
I love wonderful what do you love about
sir everything it's like New York in
some ways but it's different the
language is a little bit different
people are different so it's exciting to
to you know to meet everybody which is
part of my job yeah part of my job yeah
and to you know just the city has so
much it's like New York every corner is
something different yeah it was history
everywhere and it's excitement and young
people there's a lot going on
yeah as you can say yeah the president
was a very complimentary about it was he
originally the the embassy do you think
he'll change his mind when you come I
don't know if he'll change either by
what he comes you know I you have to
agree with them that Grosvenor Square is
kind of the center of the prime real
estate as you call it center of the
earth
right yeah it's the most important thing
but this is you as you as you get to
know this building you'll see what
function the functionality of it and the
utility of it you know going forward for
the next 50 years
this is developed maybe 10 years ago
that was probably developed in the 1950s
tell me about the [ __ ] I recognized
him it happened he was at the the old
embassy on Grosvenor Square and so he
that was painted in 1944 I believe by a
Polish artist and it's it's one that I
think every ambassador I can imagine has
looked at that and said yeah that's a
that's a great that's a great kind of
image to sit behind you so I decided to
bring that over as well and the boss
moved the boss back into the Oval Office
didn't he as soon as he day one yeah
yeah he didn't even get he wasn't even
in the Oval Office and he moved it back
so it's looking right at him I was
getting sworn in I was looking at
Winston Churchill in his office and it
looks right at the the the desk which
was given to him by Queen Victoria's
presidents he decide to use that he can
have whatever desk he wants he's a
president him being moved back into the
Oval Office do you think I think it
means something in terms of this the
relationship we have the relationship he
has personally with the country having a
Scottish mother relationship with the US
House that this is a this is a
relationship that is special both on
security and the prosperity side as well
we work so closely together and we have
our differences now and then of course
our infinity your close friends they
want you yes well known each other since
the 80s what you known each other since
the eighties since the early eighties
yeah yeah he's one of the first people I
met come into New York City from Florida
and you know everybody met remember his
meeting Donald Trump I guess he was he
was kind of a bigger than life figure in
the early 80s as well and then all the
way through to now and personality and
his views really haven't changed he's
always had you know he's been very
consistent over the years and always had
a sense of touch and a sense of knowing
what the public is feeling mr. Trump
we've come all the way from London to
talk to you before I've met him I've
interviewed him a little bit when he was
before he was elected hopefully I'll see
when he comes this time I find him to be
very tall very charismatic absolutely
believes what he says yeah why do you
think I mean you say that people will
like him when they get to know him why
do you think that he had he sort of sort
of his we would call the Marmite here in
the United Kingdom I don't need you if
you haven't equivalent in the u.s.
people either love him or hate him well
I think people don't like change
yeah and that you that will basically
answer all the questions so the people
that like change will like him
the people that have confidence as you
said the trust him enough confidence
will follow him because he is changing
and he is dramatic and he's not
following any of the patterns that
previous presidents have followed which
makes sense because previous presidents
would not be able to make this kind of
change and wouldn't make this guy look
what he's doing now in trade right
before midterm election because every
political science book would tell you
don't do it before this you've got they
always said well you can get all you
have to get done you have to get in the
first you know 180 days of a presidency
he's throwing all those rules out and he
told his audience that he was going to
do that day one and he created a
different relationship with the press a
different relationship with the people I
think that's that we've seen before him
though certainly I've seen this is
amazing this is amazing
about the duck the duck this is the
Hudson River I'm calling it the Hudson
River okay because that's not Josie
Jersey this is New York okay
that's New York yeah those are all
images of New York Henry Hudson was was
English yeah so that kind of fits in and
that's wherever they call there's a
Potomac over here but I think Hudson's a
better a better determination show and
the duck apparently gets moved around
depending well I've got a pair I've got
a pair of incoming
here so he's going to eat him pretty
soon and these are all the state flags
starting starting for the 13 colonies
and moving down that way how did you
decide on the order off them the order
of a sectioning of the country okay so
as they came in so it should be in the
right order I haven't checked but it
should be as they came in do you know
thirteen well do you know the order no I
don't but I know that Jersey is part of
the Thursday UK and it's Beth all right
fantastic the president's visit what's
planned well that will be said they
haven't been sent yeah completely so
we're looking to next week his advance
team comes over and then here they'll go
through it and they'll check all of the
venues and everything and then the
president will to me decide what he
wants to do they'll lay out various
scenarios for him I imagine I'm seeing
her majesty yes yeah so I mean he has to
see the head of state I think you know
putting his foot on the ground of
British soil I think it's his job one
very very important very symbolic
meeting a registry is is the most
important thing because she is head of
state and then from there on it will be
what the president it's not as a state
budget it's working visit Roberson yeah
so she wouldn't necessarily see her
majesty but obviously she's going to
feel yeah and what about any sort of
form of protest that might happen how's
he gonna feel about that I think that
he'll take that as they come you know
hopefully the British people will
realize that we're allies and we do have
a special relationship and well it's you
know everybody is free to do what they
want hopefully they'll hold it down a
little bit hmm I think do you think
you'll want to see Jeremy Corbyn lead
with the opposition it's up to you I
think to make that awfully no it's gonna
be a tight schedule so we'll see what he
know isn't it mr. Ellis no I can't say
no for the present I will make his
decision yeah
but it's gonna be very tight is he
looking forward to coming well he's
looking forward to coming over yeah
he'll be coming from Brussels and
they'll be have been talking about NATO
so coming to coming to his homeland his
mother's homeland I think Scotland I
think it'll head up to Scotland that
could be part of it depending on on how
the logistics work so how's our special
relationship doing do you think good
really good now Americans say great but
it is very very strong and I feel it I
talk to everybody so I talk to cab
drivers I talk to people working on the
street I talk to the politicians in town
I've talked to all of them pretty much
MPs and I've been the Birmingham
Manchester
I love no Hammond Birmingham yeah that's
right so I did that and so and I've been
all over Wales and and so I feel it
I mean I can feel it I think I have some
sense of the relationship is alive and
well and underreported so you don't sure
whether the president's good to come
here I'm not sure no this is you staying
with you at the residence yes he'll
probably be sitting it's a relative
although that you know nothing is cast
in stone his staff who are expert will
be recognized ring and making
recommendations but I think most
residents of all presidents of state as
residents jump at schedule yeah he likes
to work I read something and we got off
the plane and Singapore after a 20-hour
flight he said let's let's start great
okay he wanted to start that that's kind
of who this president knows yeah he
doesn't want to wait around how do you
think that Singapore summit went I think
it went extraordinarily well yeah
amazing I mean just from what I've seen
in the press I thought it is an amazing
assortment of contacts and advises that
he that were advising the group in terms
of agenda and rationale and all that a
big group
complicated though isn't it so it proofs
in the pudding so it depends whether
North Korea during usually yeah a lot of
it depends on your eyes about to animate
everything depends on a lot of things
but you could see the complication of
the agreement by the size of the group
that just was representing him for the
trip that's huge and these are all not
these weren't security nice wallet
political and military and majestic
societal and all that stuff and what do
you say to people who say he was meeting
with a tyrant who killed his brother and
his uncle you know we need a we're
trying to denuclearize North Korea
that's number one protect South Korea
protect Japan so you got to prioritize
your issues and I think those are those
are good issues to prioritize at this
point what's your biggest issue here in
the u in the UK what would you want the
president to focus on when he comes
president focus on what he feels is the
most important thing that day and it's
probably gonna be I think the the
relationship we have I think is always
good to talk about and always whether
you talk about specifically I think the
fact that he's here in this country is
symbolize the fact that he considers it
very important can I ask you this really
quickly because we do like a quick-fire
thing it's quite a fun thing just before
we let you go see how you feel about the
UK fish and chips or roast beef fish and
chips Guinness or bitter Guinness or
bitter ale I think better Rolling Stones
or The Beatles
rise stance Harry Potter or James Bond
James Bond for sure okay
the Tate Modern or the National Gallery
hmm that's a tough one I would say Tate
Modern
bottom-1 Allison National Gallery now
that's a toss-up yeah because it's
totally different things I would say
national gallery I was just there so I
would give them a little bit of a lead
because of the history and the
leadership and all that so national
gallery final on Sky News all the BBC
I'm not gonna put favorites in that one
no they're both doing their job perhaps
you'll put a good word with the
president for us when he comes in